ils descendent en 6 euros serait apte
à des
personnalités
maintenant on est deuxième de
ses 24 ans des brouettes
à les
aider au toit de minutes enlevées à te
dire oui troisième est maintenant à
faire comme madame là
le pouvoir le pouvoir c'est ma chute à
dire attention
25 à 3 et 2 3 pour avoir un super
tchèque non au dessus du même côté un
tchèque 9 août chez toi la photo j -cs
avec l'autre main donc c'est chez eux
que moi
les filles je suis parti à la
boulangerie j'ai acheter une baguette
ian baguette chez ima passer ma baguette
de pain et on serait à moi je serai là
la boucherie j'ai demandé un steak ou
sté qui est là
[Rires]
rien
[Musique]
là vous inquiétez pas il est gentil
non il devrait vous faire vous pouvez y
aller
non ne courait pas ré vous voyez qu'il
est pas méchant il faut pas courir
devant les chefs
mais le problème c'est que courir devant
les faits ça les excite
des gens qui m'envoient des sosies de
wham il ya plus de meuf avec des cheveux
courts et des lunettes rondes il taureau
symbole c'est super marrant vrai c'est
super mance j'ai 26 ans j'essaie d'avoir
de la barbe ou mauvais des filles de 14
ans qui me ressemble à glee ouais tu
peux m'aider juste installé un truc tu
peux mesurer avec la règle qui est là
entre les deux trous c'est un site web à
givet
22 annonces étaient les huit mois